he needed everything he could get his
hands on because i was a handful
[Music]
while i was doing a little investigating
in
an airstream trailer i think and i was
attacked from behind by the scream
character
ghostface am i saying that right i
thought it was a little too violent
maybe those movies are supposed to be
they're supposed to be violent aren't
they
it was probably just fine this is a good
long
knife he was just like stabbing me in
the back he needed everything he could
get his hands on because that was a
handful
that wasn't going down easy it was
pretty brutal
[Music]
well i was doing security for uh parker
posey's character
i think i probably would have done very
well in security field
and ended up doing security for either
the kardashians or britney spears
you know i would have been like that guy
i'd just like to think
that i had a lot going for me
25 years ago what was i eat i was eating
anything and everything back then
probably
coffee i mean i'll have a good cup of
coffee all throughout the day
and before i go to bed even maybe i
don't know probably
could have even been donuts back in the
day it's gotten too long
my answer's gotten too loud for a simple
[Music]
question